[Music]
Monday was dr. Martin Luther King jr.
day and as is the case with almost
everything lately virtually everyone on
social media seemed to parse out MLK's
words for whatever narrative they're
currently pushing in our modern times I
saw articles on how MLK was the first
environmentalist how he was an ardent
feminist a communist a socialist and
much more the one quote I tweeted of his
is perhaps his most famous I have a
dream that my four little children will
one day live in a nation where they will
not be judged by the color of their skin
but by the content of their character
I believe this quote to be as relevant
now as it was in the early 1960s but for
a whole other set of reasons in the
1960s MLK was fighting for equality
under the law and equality of
opportunity two things that we should
all absolutely believe in today those
who judge people by the color of their
skin and not the content of their
character are fighting not for equality
but for special treatment of some at the
exclusion of others this misguided
principled thinking you should treat
someone differently because of their
skin color or thinking someone should
believe what you think they should
believe because of their skin color or
any other immutable characteristic is
the essence of prejudice which means to
prejudge this is the complete reverse of
what MLK stood for and sadly this way of
thinking has infected the modern left
almost completely this is why I like
myself so many of you find yourselves on
the outside of a political bubble that
you were once safely part of for this
direct message though I don't want to
focus on the flaws of identity politics
instead I want to focus on one of the
other topics I just mentioned socialism
and for the purposes of this message I
want to put aside whether MLK was a
capitalist or a communist or a socialist
or a hybrid of any of them what I want
to discuss is some of the reaction
around the word socialism itself the
amount of people I see talking about
socialism positively is actually
staggering a tweet I set out saying
socialism is
cool even got me into a little exchange
on Twitter with the official verified
Socialist Party who explained to me that
socialism has actually never been tried
which is why we don't know if it'll work
yet perhaps they should tell that to the
people of Venezuela right now who were
fighting for food and basic services as
they watch their socialist system
collapse on top of them the ideas of
socialism that the means of production
distribution and labor should be owned
controlled and regulated by the
community as a whole are the worst sort
of collectivist ideas which exist the
very implication that the group knows
what is good for the individual that we
exist to do things for the greater good
is totally antithetical to the purpose
of being human it's your job to find
value in your work to strive for more
than you have to bring good to yourself
and the people around you and to live as
a free person as you see fit the very
idea that you should set aside your
individuality for the community as a
whole which virtually always turns into
an intolerant hostile mob is exactly why
so many have died in socialist regimes
despite the obvious failures of
socialism socialists have no problem
using the freedoms of capitalism against
itself this is perhaps the most perverse
part of the socialist worldview much
like Islamism socialism wants to use our
freedoms against us until it attains
complete power for example they use the
tools of Twitter and Facebook companies
created through the ingenuity of
individuals and the freedom of
capitalism to attack the very system
that they often live in by the way I'm
all for them being able to do this even
if I don't like what they're doing
that's the tricky part of freedom it
even applies to people and ideas you
don't like just think for a moment if we
had a socialist government in charge
right now how do you think it would be
going for free expression and free
speech how tolerant would they be of all
the people that they label Nazis and
bigots whatever you may think of Donald
Trump and the evil capitalists are they
the ones coming for
anyone's speech right now reporters
being put in jail actually President
Obama used the Espionage Act to put a
record number of reporters in jail and
as far as I know Trump who dislikes the
press to put it mildly hasn't put anyone
in prison for the crime of journalism
fortunately I see a rising tide in
America based on liberty freedom and
individual choice note how those words
themselves are somehow thought of as
evil in the socialist lexicon liberty
freedom and individual choice must all
be sacrificed for the greater good but
what they're not telling you is that the
greater good is usually for the tiny
minority in the elite protected class
their ideas have never worked and will
never work because a system built on
stripping our humanity is in direct
conflict with what it means to be human
I've said it before and I'll say it
again this perfect system which they
wish to create can never be perfect
because we humans as flawed as we are
are part of it imperfect beings cannot
create a perfect system but what we can
create is a system that always does its
best to further the advancement of human
freedom for all its flaws this is what
capitalism is which is why if you're
watching this from a capitalist society
you should consider yourself one of the
lucky ones of course in America
politicians don't outright call
themselves socialists they say that
their Democratic socialists this is
Bernie Sanders mantra as he calls for a
revolution of every kind to be a
political social or even environmental
whatever that means what Bernie forgets
or intentionally obfuscates is that the
Democratic part of this of course will
always be tossed away as socialism takes
root it's also why there's no doubt in
my mind that eventually the social
justice movement will turn on Bernie
himself and I think there's already
plenty of evidence of that democracy is
the enemy of socialism and Bernie's
trying to have it both ways there's also
a reason that the social justice
movement has such a socialist strain
within it both of these movements based
on frowning on achievement and
accomplishment and a resentment of
those who break the mold need people to
be oppressed or at least believe that
they're oppressed to survive creativity
free thought and the pursuit of your own
happiness is the antidote to both social
justice and socialism it's either that
or a life of bitterness resentment and
jealousy which in my view is less
socialism and more just anti-social
[Music]
joining me today is the founder and
director of turning-point USA a student
organization for young conservatives
which advocates for free markets and
limited government charlie Kirk
welcome to the Rubin replied to be here
big fan that's great Young Conservatives
I thought there was no such thing that
was like the Yeti or the unicorn or
Falco or something there's more of us
than you might imagine it's not all
conservative summer libertarians some
are free thinkers independence people on
the center-right we just had that
amazing conference that you were nice
enough to come down and speak at in
Florida 2600 700 students from all 50
states and it was so funny I couldn't
pay the the media outlets to cover the
same you know that's calling up in New
York Times Washington Post here we had
you know thousands of students giving up
their winter break to come here from you
know you and me and the best speakers
you know that advocate for freedom and
none of the media outlets in the
traditional media outlets covered it but
it's amazing there is a there is a
revolution happening on these campuses
but it's not it's not against you know
conservatives all this it's it's it's a
new train of thought that we want
freedom we want smaller government but
it's also fighting the culture war which
is for free speech for diversity ideas
and really against what these college
campuses have created yes so you're in
the thick of a lot of the things
obviously that we talk about here so
first I just want to talk briefly about
how we met because I think it's kind of
it kind of shows sort of how you operate
and why turning-point has taken off so
we had met about a month and a half ago
at the Horowitz Freedom Center event in
Palm Springs were you were you a
panelist there yeah I was a panelist it
is kind of helicoptering around a lot of
friends that you know attend that
conference yeah so so you were there and
everyone was like oh you gotta meet
charlie
Charlie we met for two seconds you said
a couple nice things about me and you're
like you know we're doing this our gig
in Palm Springs and a couple weeks money
to come down and talk and and then and
immediately we worked it out and and
your guys send me the paper that work
the next day and it was done and I think
that does illustrate something because
we're going to get into some of the
issues that vary agree on and some of
the things we disagree on but basically
you were like look you're you're down
for free speech that's the main thing
here and I want my audience to hear you
talk about well I you're a rational
thinker which is really rare to find in
California I'm kidding but no I mean I'm
a big fan of the show and I watch a lot
of you interviews and I know you're you
know you have a huge following amongst
young people and I mean I might you know
met you I was like yeah let's get you on
board I'm oh I've always been a gut
player for better for worse it's got me
into a little bit of trouble at times
yeah but I think net it's been positive
you just have to you have to go with
your gut and make quick decisions and
similar that's where I met Candis Owens
- who is now doing a wonderful job with
us and yeah it took me about 45 seconds
until I offered her a job so literally I
think it happened right in front of me
and then you walked up to mr. Candis was
like I just got a job and you were like
let me do something with you it's like
all right look this guy's obviously open
to some different people it's totally in
the schema what's going on you need the
diversity of ideas right if you if
you're in a room where everyone thinks
exactly the same that would be a
university so you need the diversity
ideas and you need you need to be able
to challenge your viewpoint around a
broader theme of freedom that really is
okay to have that sort of discussion
yeah so to illustrate that point so then
about I think it was the week before
Christmas you guys do this I was it the
largest conservative college we're
waiting for we're waiting for someone to
correct us we've done some research we
have never found anything been closed
yeah
you have two thousand six hundred and
fifty students from all 50 states no
one's really found anything even
comparable of size so we call it the
largest until someone corrects us yeah
well there were you had some protesters
out there yeah they they show up all the
time to everything there but but there
was true diversity of thought there only
you it was also sort of a Rubin report
reunion for me because Prager was there
and Gutfeld was there all my best friend
Candace was
they're obviously and and a whole bunch
of Sherpa Tom jr. was there is just a
series of people I went up there and I
talked about being gay married and I
talked about being pro-choice and and a
bunch of other things that if you were
to poll the average conservative that
perhaps they're not for I think gay
marriage maybe it's a little a little
different at this point but I got a
standing ovation and everywhere that I
multiple times well yeah yeah budget
times and and everywhere that I went for
those two three days that I was there
and have been by no means was this just
me I mean Ben Shapiro came out it was
like it was like Elvis it was yeah I'm
gonna say it was like the Rolling Stones
seriously is nuts but that happened to
everybody I went for breakfast I need
coffee before I talk to people yet I'm
literally there's a line of 100 people
start popping up it's like they start
swarming yeah but that said something to
me beyond the politics that there's
something else going on with young
people right now where they actually as
the young people say they're they're
really woke yes what's happening here
well and it's that diversity idea is
that I think illustrates what makes our
organization so unique so a reporter
came up to me and he was totally
dishonest guys like well this this feels
like a Donald Trump rally and I said how
could you possibly say that sure we have
Trump jr.
we have Gorka we also Austin Peterson I
ran for president on in the Libertarian
Party all right we have Ruben who is not
a leftist anymore but he's somewhere out
there right he believes in freedom Yeah
right
we've been Shapiro who literally led the
nevertrump in it
right we have a huge diversity of ideas
and each speaker was respected was given
standing ovations was challenged
appropriately and I think that really
says something about this new
Conservatory in movement that we're
helping create yeah which is we don't
have to agree on 100% of conservative
dogma let's just get the big stuff right
the big stuff is America a great country
yes it's free enterprise a good thing
yes you know its freedom something that
we should really embrace as a general
idea yes is socialism bad yes that's
just pretty much the main key points and
the rest of the stuff we can argue and
disagree with respectfully yeah when did
you wake up to some of this stuff just
tell me a little bit about your growing
up and your situation I was
crazy crazy kid growing up grew up in
the northwest suburbs of Chicago always
was a conservative Republican growing up
around a lot of leftists and liberals in
my public high school and our you young
and conservative like I because I love
history and I was always contrarian
right so I'd always be challenging my
teachers my parents were generally
Republican right they weren't you know
necessarily political but they were
center-right O'Reilly Factor watching
you know Republicans that I always used
to say and then I would always just
challenge teachers that would say that
you know all conservatives want to do is
kill poor people and you know pollute
the environment the typical talking
points right and being the kind of you
know rebel I guess you could say I'd
always challenge the teachers and say
well no Ronald Reagan lifted more people
out of poverty than your crazy social
programs that Jimmy Carter drove nuts
and I found enjoyment in it and you know
the further down that rabbit hole you
get the more you read Milton Friedman
the more you understand the foundational
principles and ideas at a young age I
just became on fire for politics and for
economics and long story short I started
this organization when I was 18 instead
of going to college and ended up being a
wonderful decision and helped really
place myself in a movement that was
waiting to be grown and this is
something a lot bigger than just
politics this is the fight for the soul
of the country and it has to start on
college campuses and it's really the
struggle for our generation and it's
it's really if you divide it it's do we
want do we believe America is the
greatest country in the history of the
world and do we believe freedom is a
good thing or do we want to go a
completely different direction that
looks much more like a European
socialist democracy that does not honor
civil liberties that does not honor
private property and really deteriorates
everything that made America a great
place that that's the decision our
generation has to make it's kind of
funny you're sort of like the non
Silicon Valley version of like Bill
Gates or Steve Jobs didn't quite
flattering did you go to college or
dropped out of college and but now
you're talking to college people when
did you realize that that was the place
that that this battle had to be yeah and
the first couple years of starting
turning-point USA it started as kind of
a generic student organization but just
like any good innovator and entrepreneur
I listened and I learned and I realized
there was such frustration amongst
self-identified conservative
libertarians on campus that were not
being properly channeled and organized
they felt as if they were being targeted
and that they were being suppressed and
their ideas were not being allowed to be
heard and we made a decision that
turning-point the for a couple years is
let's not just fight the political war
let's double down and fight the culture
war and that we can be the champions of
free speech and we can be the
ambassadors of freedom we're really you
see these campuses I call them islands
at the Talat arianism you know their
idea of diversity is a group of people
that all look different but they think
the same yeah
that's not diversity and so Turning
Point is benefited tremendously over the
last couple years of really being the
champions of free speech and also saying
hey we're not Republicans we're not
conservatives we're not libertarians you
can call us all that stuff that's fine
we have members that are across that
whole spectrum as long as you believe in
freedom you believe America is a great
country welcome aboard
do you think the idea of having that
kind of wide tent is part of the appeal
like I think people are so sick of the
labels and all that was cool
I spend actually most of the weekend
hanging out with with Austin but part of
it also hanging out with Tommy and
Candice and a whole bunch of other
people and I was like there really is
and then and then you know Alison
Stuckey was there and a couple other
people and I was like wow these people
actually really do think different
things totally and and my libertarian
side usually goes to kind of where
Austin that but I was like we we're
we're all having dinner after that's a
great thing and I was like this is great
we're having real discussions yeah we're
really digging into it and there is that
disagreement but if you put them all in
a room they but they get the big stuff
right yeah right you know do we believe
that free enterprise has been a net
positive for humanity do we believe the
Constitution is a great political
document that should be preserved
protected and better understood do we
believe America has been a wonderful you
know net benefit for Humanity you know
over the last 200 years they probably
agree wholeheartedly and all that it's
the other stuff where they start to have
a little philosophical differences but
that disagreement is not being found on
the left right now if you disagree with
one core tenet of leftist dogma you're
ostracized you're kicked out and that
shows there they're not a diverse
political movement the new modern
American Left they're extremely
intolerant of differing opinions and I
don't have to talk for you I mean
what you think you're acting as my agent
but listen I would gladly I said this
when I had Shapiro on last week I will
gladly give the exact same speech that I
gave to you guys a couple weeks ago I
would love to give that exact same
speech to any progressive or Democrat
and you guys standing ovations but I'm
looking to get my mag a hat wearing
students right but you give that speech
to the Young Democrats socialists of
America conference coming up in a couple
months
you'll get boos and you'll get weak
shouldn't hear things we disagree with
yeah you know bolshevik you know forever
it's these people have have translated
into total authoritarianism do you see a
moment where both of the movements sort
where you would argue the Conservatives
sort of lost their place thus lost the
culture war or and where they left sort
of went bananas yeah I think the length
has gone bananas just by default of
their positions they really in inside of
every leftist is a totalitarian waiting
this you know screaming to get out is a
great quote I always use yeah it's
because when you argue for total
government power and total government
control of health care and schools and
private economic decisions that can
easily be translated into the monitoring
of personal capacity decisions right
that that translation is quite simple
and I always say to a leftist that says
well I believe in you know civil
liberties but I also believe in
government-run schools and healthcare as
I say if you don't trust the government
to help you know to monitor your own
personal life wine earth when you trust
the government throughout all these
other institutions where I think
conservatives have gotten it wrong over
the last thirty years is where
conservatives have become mislabeled and
sometimes some considers believe this to
want to do social engineering I think
I'm gonna have angelical Christian I'm a
pro-life conservative but I also believe
government should have barriers in
trying to instill those values upon
society I think the best persuasion the
best capacity for good is done through
churches and local community movements
and individuals persuading individuals
and writing books and doing podcasts not
through government doing massive social
engineering programs so I think that's
where conservatives have lost their way
and that's where the left is currently
trying to stake their claim is there
anything that you think government does
well no no I think government is a
necessary evil I think it's necessary
for
providing from the national defense
because that is something that whether
we like it or not you have to you have
to delegate some of our personal freedom
to you know have a some sort of a civil
society but government by its essence if
you read what Milton Friedman has said
they're incentivized to be inefficient
they're incentivized by definition to
not be able to provide the best possible
good or service for the individual so
look the private sector does everything
better whether it be the inefficiency
the post office or Medicare is bankrupt
Social Security doesn't serve the people
you know effectively everything
government touches goes to crap and the
private sector is by definition more
efficient because if you don't do it
well you're not going to exist much
longer what do you think is the best way
of getting that message across that
government just doesn't do things well
because I think it's just so built-in to
people partly because our education is
shirt and screwed up or whatever that
they just feel the government should
just do things so I saw Bernie tweeted
the other day this video of all these
millionaires saying and I responded yeah
so I retweeted it which got like twenty
thousand retweets because it was like
it's all these millionaires saying we
should be taxed more we should be taxed
more well what what intellectual hip-hop
it's such lies it's like boy a what's
stopping you from pay that's what I
suppose just send more money to the IRS
numbskull or it's right but it's like
but okay so but yet Bernie's tweet gets
something like fifty thousand retweets
and not that it's all about retweets and
all but it's true he has high engagement
with this but to me it's just lazy
thinking it is lazy so virtuous if it's
so virtuous to keep giving money to the
guns right why do you need the
government to tell you to do it and
really at its core if you look at the
philosophical difference between really
the culturally Marxist left which is
what they're becoming and the free
thinking individualist you know
individual libertarian conservative
right which is the new you know
intellectual position that is growing
you know quicker than even the left its
we might want good things to happen in
society but don't tell me to do them at
gunpoint
yeah and the left on the other hand I
don't think their intentions are very
good I think they want permanent
political power but Bernie Sanders for
example he is so convicted that he is
right he wants to use the absolute
authority on and unlimited power of the
state to put a gun to your head
and say you have to have a 70% tax rate
because someone is starving on the
street I would rather live in a society
that has the same tax rate for everyone
10% and we dig deeply say are we going
to take care of that person on the
street through charity through private
philanthropy and through being better
people and if you look at when
socialism's implemented you see the
moral disintegration of society you look
at Spain you look at France you look at
Europe they don't have anything as
private philanthropy any more private
charity has disappeared in Europe
because government takes care of it and
that I think that is such an important
point to make so going back to your
question how do you illustrate this to a
young person you ask the fundamental
question do you trust a government that
word trust is so important because in in
that word trust that really feels
personal all right do you trust the
government 99% of young people say no
then you ask the next question then why
do you want to make government bigger as
soon and they'll say I don't well then
you're not a social so you're not a
leftist then let's talk about how we can
really shrink the size of government and
put power back into the hands of people
and it's important to note also even
though you think government might want
to do something it doesn't mean federal
government has to do it local government
is much more accountable to the citizens
than some bureaucrat in DC that you're
never going to meet and so those are
those are arguments that you know we've
found to be very effective yeah it's
interesting you mentioned intentions and
I always try my best not to impugn
intentions of others I think that
especially on the left right now
obviously I think these people have a
lot of bad ideas now of course some of
them have bad intentions but most of
them don't most average people don't
wake up thinking we're I'm gonna do bad
today they actually think they're doing
good most of them yeah do you think some
of their leaders actually have bad and
without a doubt yes absolutely and not
all of them but some of them and you
look back to the original writings and
the original thought process behind the
Great Society Lyndon Baines Johnson who
bragged on multiple times that the
implementation the Great Society and all
the social programs around it will keep
african-americans dependent and keep
them voting for generations documented
in the presidential record Lyndon Baines
Johnson said that and so I think the
Democratic Party is full of people with
great intentions but its leaders have
realized and calculated but if they can
keep the government programs continuing
for just long enough not getting people
out of poverty but keep people surviving
within poverty they will have a
permanent political base so if you ask
the question if African Americans
actually rose out of poverty and saw
their wages get higher and their schools
get better and their communities
you know flourish are they going to keep
voting for government welfare programs
that are the basis of the Democratic
Party absolutely not
yeah they're not they're gonna break out
of that so I think the intentions of the
Democratic Party
the followers I'm never ever gonna
impune them I'm not going to call them
deplorable Zoar anything like they call
us I think most of the followers
Democratic Party actually really good
people but the leaders we must question
their motives because if you look at the
failures of the welfare system in this
country it is undoubtable that they're
protecting a system that benefits them
politically is this also partly why the
media is going so hysterical right now
like have you noticed just in the last
couple weeks we've shifted a little bit
out of Russia hysteria but now it's
about Trump's mental capacity and it's
like now and see how they coordinate it
I mean you really if you just look
telling you they got to got like a group
text message chain going I'm talking
they got like John King Anderson Cooper
Don Lemon Rachel Maddow I think they're
all just group texting I'm not kidding I
want to down that conspiracy theory can
you cut me when you start to have all
three television stations open of CBS
this morning and CNN you know with Cuomo
and MSNBC Good Morning Joe and they're
talking about the exact same thing
literally the segment's are literally
produced the same I don't think that's a
conspiracy it there's got to be some
sort of Talking Points Memo they send
out just that early in the morn but does
that show you were talking points memo
or just general group thing no I think
it's general group Ian but I also I
think they understand that they have to
be coordinated to be effective which
there's nothing I think wrong with that
effectively we conservatives do the same
thing without even realizing it you
listen to Rush Limbaugh you listen to
Dennis Prager and you listen to Sean
Hannity the talking points are usually
quite similar because you know you watch
Fox and Friends in the morning that kind
of sets the agenda and I'm not I'm not
attacking the Democrats for being that
but if you look at why the media is
going so far off the rails it's they
will never accept the fact that this
presidency is actually large in part a
wonderful success is that the president
is fulfilling his campaign promises
we're seeing unprecedented economic
prosperity and you're seeing people's
lives actually get better and so they
have to go down to this tabloid
journalism or report on this fake book
they have to continue down this Russia
hysteria because if this president
succeeds which he is and he will what
else do they have they have gone so far
all in that this guy is a psychopathic
nutjob they will they will lose all
institutional credibility and political
relevance you know it's funny right when
Trump started the campaign I kept saying
that if you keep calling this guy Hitler
you are painting yourself into a really
bad corner and it cheapens Hitler to yak
about that Hitler was one of the worst
mass murderers in human history who
killed 15 million people and they have
people once a week on those networks
equate him to the rise of the Third
Reich what does that do is it cheapens
the evil of Hitler and is that one of
the worst thing you could possibly do
more trying to educate the next
generation
everyone's Hitler no one's Hitler then
maybe what Hitler did wasn't that bad
maybe Hitler was democratically elected
and had a supreme court that kept them
in balance you see it I'm saying that
right you know it cheapens the evil of
the Nazi Empire when they start to make
these comparisons to Donald Trump and
Hitler it's really and also the way this
stuff just goes downstream I mean
because then it's you start calling all
your intellectual opponents Nazis then
you say it's okay to punch the Nazis
well where does that end can we punch
the not tonight
life can we blow up there exactly I'm
called a Nazi all the time and I mean
it's one of the most intellectually just
dangerous arguments to make when you and
when everyone becomes a fascist even
though there is no evidence of that what
really has your political movement
become yeah
where'd the words freedom and liberty
and the words that I now use a lot how
did they get so MUC tup that they
started feeling wrong you know what I
mean in the cultural relevance of things
well I think it I think it's starting
with the misrepresentation of what
freedom and liberty really is I mean the
left tries to be the movement of freedom
a lot of young people that follow Bernie
Sanders actually think they're on the
side of freedom they think that Bernie
Sanders is fighting for political
freedom and economic freedom and he's
going to fight for the little guy when
in reality when his ideas are
implemented which he's an open socialist
the power always gets concentrated at
the top the rulers are the ones that get
rich the people that have the best
connections the best lobbyists are the
ones that benefit tremendously
you look no further than Venezuela or
cube are anywhere where socialism has
tried it's the poor people that voted
these guys into power they could that
are worst off mm-hmm and so we have to
be able to make the argument freedom is
not only a really cool thing freedom is
not only a great idea but it actually
works like freedom when implemented
actually makes people's lives better it
you know freedom would be a difficult
argument if it was not only like really
cool to make the argument like yeah you
do whatever you want to do when you want
to do it how you want to do it that
would be great yeah but we actually get
to make the argument that in
practicality freedom is the greatest
thing to make people's lives better for
innovations for medical advances for
technological you know prosperity
nothing comes even close to allowing
freedom to to ensue so what do you say
when someone says I hear this all the
time you know well if the government
doesn't do these things these social
programs or if the government takes away
food stamps or whatever it is that we
just don't know if the private sector or
churches and synagogues whatever we just
don't know that that'll pick up the
slack and then if that doesn't happen we
end up with this permanent class of
under underserved people that have no
way fundamentally disagree with that and
so this is where the world views I think
collide is where the left they try to
build this I think a lot of it is trying
for guilt right they actually want to
help as many people as possible they
feel so bad that people are suffering
they want someone else that do it for
them so the first thing I do is I
challenge how much money are you giving
their charity how much are you doing to
actually help the homeless guy in the
side corner yeah and then what if ten
million people did what you did
secondly never underestimate the good
that Americans will do when people are
in need hurricanes natural disasters
famines fires Americans always step up
Americans voluntarily gave 500 billion
dollars away to charity last year
imagine if our tax rate was 10 percent
imagine if there was really a national
rallying call to double our charitable
efforts we can easily give away
trillions of dollars Wow trillions of
dollars that's the size of the welfare
state and I would make a compelling
argument that local churches charities
and municipalities do a heck of a lot
better job of serving the people than
the federal government bureaucrat a lot
you know sending money to Washington DC
is that actually gonna help the poor
single mother in Miami or is going to
the local Catholic Church and getting
$5,000 which might be a lot of money to
you actually gonna help them a lot more
than sending that $5,000 Washington DC I
will argue fiercely against someone who
says that a government bureaucrat is
going to help an underprivileged
individual better than a private charity
or individuals helping individuals so
you said a couple nice things about
Trump so I want to get into some of some
of the specifics on that please but so
one of the things that I've said is that
Trump basically was the bull in the
china shop and he just went in and just
up and did everything and I actually
think that right now that's a net good
because there were a lot of bad things
happening before there's some fertile
ground for some good ideas so on that
level I'm for what's happening when I
had Eric Weinstein sitting in that chair
he said that he would have preferred it
to be a panther in a china shop meaning
it would have just knocked over a few
things maybe not though there I don't
think that that exists that's that was
the point of our disagreement I just
think it just doesn't exist where you
get to selectively choose where things
are gonna be knocked off the shelves and
all that Seb Korca was speaking at the
turning point of it felt was doing this
whole thing about how somebody was doing
it backstage continued on stuff it's not
but but gorko is saying how Trump was
the I think he said the Icebreaker going
sure the glacier basically and what I
noticed that was there was a theme with
the speakers where everyone basically
acknowledged that there are issues with
Trump I don't think anyone went up there
and said this guy is the perfect thing
or you know this is exactly how we
wanted it but there was a sense of this
was the only way it could have happened
is that basically where you fall so I'm
one of the few you know outward and
vocal millennial Trump you know
supporters out there not few I should
say in kind of this work world a
conservative pundit tree if you will
everyone tries the heads right and
there's some good and some bad and I've
obviously gone all in and I'm glad I
have and I'm happy to walk through you
know the philosophical you know
reasoning for that so look look Donald
Trump was never supposed to be president
at States just look going back a little
bit running in a crowded field of
Republican candidates and noun Singh the
day
after Jeb Bush announced his candidacy
which I think was no coincidence and I
think he saw Jeb Bush announce like
screw it if that guy's running I'm
running it took down the bush dynasty
that out a hundred ten million dollars
to spend and then took down the Clinton
dynasty took down the media dynasty in a
way that's totally unprecedented and if
you look at the values that he
represents in my personal opinion he is
one of the best chances Western
civilization has to continue he believes
America is the greatest country in the
history of the world he's been a fierce
critic of socialism his visit this
Poland was a 40-minute critique of the
fall of the USSR he believes that the
Constitution's the greatest political
document ever written look no further
than his appointment of Gorsuch in these
circuit court judges more than any of
that he believes that America as an idea
must be preserved protected and advanced
and is he an imperfect vessel of course
we're all imperfect vessels does he
tweet things that I might not always
agree with yeah sure but but if the
ideas that he's implementing I would
make a compelling argument he's the most
conservative president in a hundred
years even more so than Ronald Reagan he
is doing more bold reforms and he's
fighting to do what he said he was going
to do even in the face of unprecedented
opposition whether it be the embassy
moving to Jerusalem opening up our
natural resources getting out of TPP
getting out of the Paris climate court
agreement this is stuff that is not
supposed to happen right do you think
Jeb Bush would be doing this sudden give
me a break no way so basically do you
think he was the last chance for
conservatives I think I say that but I
kind of think that's a compelling
argument that know that if you look when
McCain ran or Romney ran Romney was
against women with his binders of women
they said McHugh no McCain was racist
blah blah blah that to me the most
compelling argument is that none of
these guy you think Marco Rubio will
beat Hillary you know or Jeb would is
somehow beat Hillary No
so that putting aside some of my
reservations for a moment this was the
only way that any of these ideas were
gonna get that bet that's correct so let
me play out the alternative scenario
Hillary Clinton is president and she has
control of the Senate and control the
house and she's just advancing this
radically destructive Obama agenda
instead Donald Trump for any of the
disagreements people might have around
him the results really speak for
themselves the economic prosperity that
we're seeing right now that you can put
six trillion dollars of new wealth
created in this country but even more
than that I'm telling you there was a
referendum on the ballot and I was there
on Wisconsin I was there in Michigan I
was there in Pennsylvania with Donald
Trump jr. for weeks on end the people
that showed up to vote that hand vote in
30 years
you know what they were really voting
for they were voting that America is the
greatest country that has through the
world and here's finally someone who's
gonna fiercely defend it against the
permanent political class that's
important because who else to represent
that permanent political class than
Hillary Clinton like she was the worst
person that Democrats could have put up
in a change election here's someone
whose husband was impeached who
constantly cheated on her
she's the most uncharismatic possible
person to put up and here's a guy who
you know what he's gonna blow it up
great that's who I'm gonna vote for and
you look a lot of what he's doing he has
shrunk the size a lot of these federal
bureaucracies and he's fighting a lot of
these entrenched media and political
establishments that honestly I never
thought we would see such a champion
against which brings me great
satisfaction what do you think about the
intellectual side of Trump like I get
what you're saying that the broad ideas
of freedom in America and liberty and
those things and I basically agree that
that's he does understand those things
in terms of just like the intellectual
or philosophical side do you think he
really has an understanding of the
issues or do you think that maybe isn't
even important I don't think it's that
important I've spent considerable time
with him and his family and I can say
this his his understanding of why
America is the greatest country in the
history of the world why free enterprise
matters and actually how to benefit
country as a whole is is just as good if
not better than some of these
politicians they might be able to recite
all these intellectual and philosophical
quotes because this is a president that
you know what he's been through
bankruptcy trials he's been through
hiring and firing hundreds of people and
you know you running a business and me
running a business that develops
character in someone you just got to say
making payroll dealing with regulators -
versus some of these senators that have
been you know orders and thinkers their
whole life give me a break right so I
have a deep amount of respect it doesn't
bother me that you know CNN says oh he
talks to the fourth grade level give me
a break you know seriously he talks the
way that the guy in Northeast Iowa has
been waiting for someone to talk to in a
while so I completely dismissed that as
an argument and I look at what he's
accomplished as a person which is
totally amazing and what he's fighting
for every single day and he
gets the big stuff correct he really
does and I challenged some of my you
know critics on the right who else in
that field of 17 Republican candidates
would have nominated Gore CIFAS Supreme
Court moved the embassy advocated for
the greatest you know middle-class tax
cut in American history not back down on
some of these core issues it's really if
I would have said here's XYZ candidate
let's just pretend this is you know in
the Republican primary and in the first
11 months would get this done most
conservative pundits would say where do
I sign you know seriously you know and
he has he has advanced more conservative
pro-freedom libertarian ideas than any
of these candidates what most of these
candidates would so then what do you
make of the conservative class that
hates him so I'm talking about like the
David Frum crew that that whole yeah
French the rest of these guys that
really just hate him even though I agree
he has put forth a lot of the idea that
they've been yammering about for the
last twenty years I mean look I I have a
lot of respect for those publications
because of their history I'm just I'm
challenged I I'm really wondering is it
a personal vendetta they have against
this guy is a personality disagreement
because policy wise and implementation
of the people he's put in place to make
decisions the cabinet positions I mean
this is a much more conservative
president than george w bush and
remarkably more effective than HW and
already in twelve months much more
consequential than ronald reagan and and
so i'm wondering i want the balls in
their court right because to be so hyper
critical just automatically against
someone who is fighting for your ideas
every single day i I'm just I'm really
wondering what was it is it a
personality disagreement or is it kind
of just I don't want to be wrong type of
thing like I'm cheering for his demise
because I'm a posed him for so long I
think it's also I just want to be liked
by mainstream which is the other thing
right like I I've now created a whole
new form of enemies I never thought
possible which is like these rabid
welcome to my world you know seriously
these rabid media elites that are like
always close to the Trump people we must
try to destroy him and like all right
fine whatever you know yeah the hatred
for this man is is uncalled for is there
anything that he's doing that you're not
happy with so I'll give you odds that's
a great question I so I'll give you
something that just in the last and
you know what you're gonna say and I'll
probably agree okay so in the last ten
days so he basically instructed Jeff
session so that we're gonna grant okay
so to me states rights if you care about
that constant during that you said he
loves so much and all those things the
states should be able to make laws that
they want and the federal government
should not impede on the library we have
something called the Tenth Amendment etc
etc so in a case like this what's
happening there how is there such a
disconnect between the ideas of freedom
that you laid out so eloquently and then
what sessions is doing in practice i I
can't I can't explain it well and I
won't defend it because I don't agree
with it look I'm a big defender of
individual freedom and liberty and I get
a lot of hate from my social sense or
conservative friends when I argue for
decriminalization of drugs I've never
done drugs in my life and I don't plan
to but someone wants to do it cool right
whatever you know put whatever you want
to put in your body as long it doesn't
harm someone else so this is something
that I think actually not making the
correct decision on but you know what
I'm happy to say that said it publicly
and you know if I if I find someone like
Jeff session who's gets most of the
stuff right he's been great on guns he's
been great on some of those other stuff
but I don't think he's correct on this
marijuana issue and I don't think he's
correct politically it says the majority
of Americans don't agree on this issue
and to go after people that are
peacefully doing business that's really
what they're going after this is the
financial transaction side that doesn't
make a lot of sense to me that's not on
the correct side of economic freedom but
you know what this agreement is a
healthy thing right and we need to
challenge our cabinet officials and
challenge our leaders when we don't see
eye to eye with them and I think this is
something that I think runs in the face
of some of our core beliefs and tenets
yeah it just seems like so ideologically
inconsistent when I think it's fighting
for States right he's been fighting for
states rights in that look even now
you've got people on the Left fighting
for states rights
ridiculous which makes no sense because
now they're they're trying to defend
sanctuary cities so yeah therefore
doesn't mean it's right and against the
federal government right doesn't
mechanism but I will say this I think a
lot of it is stemmed from this kind of
old holdover war on drugs that Ronald
Reagan declared in the 1980s which was
an abysmal and total failure right the
statistics speak for themselves that you
know the war on recreational marijuana
has not been a net benefit for the
taxpayer for society in general again I
come from the general world view that
the greatest change does not come
through
in policy or if your government
bureaucrats and so to be intellectually
consistent I won't defend penalizing
people that are peacefully selling you
know cannabis to other people whether it
be for medically recreationally and but
here's the thing I went to high school
in northwest suburbs of Chicago this is
the story I always tell people say
Charlie you're conservative how can you
possibly hold its position no it's
always that these Tea Party groups which
I love I love the Tea Party I love those
people right but they're they're my you
know that I call them like the hardcore
group right like they're the Alex Jones
you know flag-carrying people that are
really hardcore they're really big in
the conspiracy and you know there's
there always ask me Charlie how can you
possibly be on the side of the
criminalization of marijuana I said
listen I went to high school in the
North the suburbs of Chicago okay
I remember after football games like
kids have backpacks full of marijuana
now marijuana is illegal in Illinois
marijuana is illegal in Cook County and
there were cops in our halls looking for
it all the time it was not working okay
let's just put it that way the Reds are
wanted it found it the kids like me who
didn't want any to do with it just
walked away what what other better
illustration of freedom than that you
don't want to engage with it just walk
away find somewhere else to do it
we didn't need to pay you know the DEA
or FBI units to go do locker room raids
is something that kids were
recreationally and peacefully doing I'm
not a proponent of it I would support a
charity to try to educate students not
to do it cuz I think of Rupe you know
had a net negative but why is it
government's role to socially engineer
us especially when it's a non-lethal
substance I always think it's so
interesting like look I now I mean
California where it's now yeah now
recreationally legal but I have a
medical marijuana card and I've hurt my
knee playing bass yeah well a couple
years ago the places right over there
I'd like to walk you in there just to
see what's going on before you're not
gonna persuade me to it's fine whatever
I just think it would be fun to go in
there with you and yeah that would be
what was going on and go where my mag I
had that would not go well no no that's
not that would get a hit of salt there
but I think it's funny because anytime
that I ever bought weed illegally like
when I lived in New York City yeah just
get it from whoever the weed guy was I
don't even know who that we've got
exactly but I never once in 15 years or
whatever I never had the guy selling
weed say hey you want to buy crack you
want to buy coke you want right now and
yet we can go to prescription plate you
can go to a psychiatrist all in it
every drug and it's a hundred times
worse and it's and it's chemically
addictive yeah right so look I know
plenty of people that have had stories
that tell me Charlie if it wasn't from
medicinal marijuana I would have gone to
narco substances and I would have been a
really a worse place right and so fine
but that's the core tenant of freedom
and I think what you're seeing here is
most of our turning point followers
would find sympathy with my argument and
this is okay this is a natural change in
a political movement as time goes on but
and the fact that jeff sessions holds
that position maybe he has an experience
that I haven't experienced right that is
really personal to him maybe he's seen
you know marijuana do something horrible
to a family member of people in local
community Alabama I'll disagree with
that probably not like whatever I'm
trying to give the benefit the doubt
because I think he's generally a good
person I always try to give the benefit
of doubt when people hold these
positions yeah I just think it's not the
right policy but you know what in 20
years you're gonna see the conservative
libertarian majority similar to Rand
Paul advocate for this and then we'll be
able to point out the hypocrisy the
left's say okay hold on a second like
we're cool with people being able to
sell what they want to sell it long
doesn't harm someone else why are you
trying to tell me I can't frack this oil
field in the Permian Basin right right
if you want to have like it into it if
you want to be intellectually consistent
right huh all right I want to do one
other thing on the social stuff and then
we'll move over to some articles oh no I
know I said listen I never had a lie
against the grain you immediately sat
down you're like anything let's go all
right seriously challenge but here we
are so well I don't think this want to
be too much of a challenge but I think
it's an interest in sure it just shows
how things have shifted so at the
Republican convention Peter Thiel an
openly gay man great link spoke before
Trump he said I'm a proud gay man got a
standing ovation
then Trump gets up there talks about
weights him out yeah TRO right points
him and he said it makes me very happy
because the exact quote he said because
he uh makes me very happy that was a
hand okay what's that that the fact that
there's been such a wholesale shift in
that that even right now Ted Cruz or the
guys that you might consider a little
more of the Christian conservatives well
Mike Huckabee right okay so so where you
come from basically as far as I can tell
don't really see this as an issue
anymore is that a fair price that's
correct
and and so let me dive deeper
also posed a hypothetical to some of the
leftists watching this
Peter TL openly gay man gets a standing
ovation the Republican National
Convention and then pointed as the you
know pointed out by the candidate do you
think that an evangelical pastor that
was pro-israel that might be a Democrat
would have even been allowed to speak at
the Democratic National Convention or
given a standing ovation they booed God
when he was doing that was when it was
mentioned okay they literally did what
is the shift here the shift is the
Republican Party is beginning to realize
hey let's party of freedom like it's
cool if you want to do that I think it's
it's a real sea change because even if
you see Rand Paul beginning to you know
endorse more of those you know favorable
drug policy positions on the side of
freedom or gay marriage you know you're
starting to see a sea change where it's
becoming the soul-searching the
Republican Party as we donor the last 30
years is what's the one thing that ties
our party together
freedom freedom freedom and I think
that's why you're starting to see that
and the left they can't reconcile what
what ties them together oppression you
know like it's the oppression Olympics
if I kind suffers more you know and I
think that's a really good thing
segue to one one final point is what I
think is the position that needs to be
articulated better is I have no problem
if you know gay marriage whatever like I
believe marriage one man one woman
that's my own personal position right
but I'm never gonna tell government to
have someone live a life I think it's
cool you're married I think it's great
and you should have all the same tax
benefits adopt children it's great right
but now you feel the same way about you
well it's fines like whatever like but
that's that's more of like a
generational perspective here's where I
think Republican conservatives need to
really fight hard and I think you agree
is the religious liberty stuff is are
you gonna force a Christian Baker to
make a cake for a gay couple that is not
the same thing as being cool with gay
marriage and the left is trying to make
a moral equivalency argument of the
civil rights of the 1960s and someone
having to violate the religious
conscience to make a cake for a gay
couple because they want it they want to
have fascism where you can go into a
private company and say you have to
produce a product or service because we
have a certain you know lifestyle that's
dangerous and wrong and I think that's
where the fight needs to happen and
that's where I think we can actually win
conference over do you think also the
nology is the answer to some of those
problems where we've kind of sucks that
you know I did in my Praeger you video
from last year which is excellent thanks
I mean that was the line that really
caught on because I don't want to force
know that Baker to do something just as
if there was a you could use any example
here but if there was a Jewish artist
who had a website that they take
commissions for paintings I wouldn't
want the government forcing them to
paint neo-nazi paintings it's exactly
the same thing yeah and would you want
to force you know a Muslim wedding hall
to have to host you know someone that is
a great critic of his salon right that
would violate one of the tenants one of
the pillars of Islam right but for
whatever reason the left is you know way
overstepping their bounds and the
Circuit Court of California is like lost
their freaking mind
seriously where they don't realize the
slippery slope that they're engaging in
here where if you have a private
business with their own private
conscience they should be allowed to
accept and deny business as they see fit
especially if it's business that takes
pre-planning like such as a wedding cake
or photography the only argument they
might make is if you're you know running
a fast food restaurant but you know what
if someone wants to be a racist or a
bigot they have that right no one's
gonna go buy products from them anymore
right that's how you win arguments
without having to use the government gun
on people's heads which again I think
that's the argument that we have to make
but if look if a gay couple wants to get
married that's cool like whatever that's
the law of the land move on to bigger
battles like religious liberty and
freedom
all right let's shift a little bit to
some religions okay you are a Christian
conservative that's correct just that
phrase trigger is a certain amount of
people so first off what what is a
Christian conservative which always
stuns me so I do a lot of campus tour
I'll tell you a quick story a lot of
campus tours and I go through my litany
of what I call hard truths told by
Charlie Kirk and I'll say you know
socialism is the greatest killer of
humanity last 100 years and I'll say
free enterprises of the greatest
economic system ever and then I'll say
three words and it drives them so crazy
I say God is real and it's like they
just start shaking ah the left they
think they dare they don't know how to
handle it and half the place loves it
half the place hates it I don't know why
that's so triggering so
a Christian first and foremost I believe
you know Jesus Christ as the Son of God
and he came down and we you know he died
for all our sins and we have a good
documentation of that and we could
debate and discuss that whatever but as
a Christian I'm you know I believe that
you know we are called to try to advance
the kingdom of God and the Ministry of
Jesus Christ as many people as possible
and as peacefully as possible obviously
right so that's how I try to live my own
personal life and make my own personal
decisions as a conservative I'd say let
me provide everything so I I don't see
you proselytizing religion though in the
public way I've heard you speak before
sure and I've never heard you push that
so I say it every so often when asked
but I look at my speaking no different
than sometimes doing a job right so a
plumber electrician that is not going to
tell every person he turns around the
corner like hey have you heard this
crowd you know what I mean so you have
to you don't want to be too offsetting
and off-putting but I also try to you
know through my some of my platforms you
know talk about my personal beliefs no
matter how triggering it might be to
other people and I'm like campus tours I
try to you know advance but of course I
could probably do a better job of it but
with that being said I would consider
myself more as a Conservatorium which I
find to be a new breed of you know
ideology which you and I talked about
and some people have already been
labeling themselves as such and I find
no contradiction between my Christian
worldview and my political philosophy in
fact I find great amount of you know
synchrony actually between what I find
what I believe theologically and what I
believe spiritually and religiously it's
also what I advocate for politically
which is essentially the non-aggression
principle and you know believing in
productive people and free societies
should be able to make your choices as
you see fit as long as you're not
harming someone else how did Christians
end up as so much of the butt of what
the left hates because you can open up
every day another BuzzFeed article
mocking isn't it right Christians and
Mike and HuffPo and the they all love
the Bible
oh yeah them oh yeah it's nuts but how
did that happen
well so I think what happened is that
Christian conservatives fell for a trap
that they really should have rejected
which is we might hold these truths very
near and dear to our heart the
jakoli and biblically and spiritually
religiously but I think where the line
was crossed is in the 60s and 70s and
80s where we tried to impose those
beliefs through government policy where
people then inherently have a rejection
to it similarly how people are rejecting
the left imposing their crazy worldview
upon us right I think that was a big
mistake because it created this kind of
counter-revolution which is I don't want
to have to live the way some Christian
and Alabama wants me to live does that
make sense so it's it's the imposition
of those values through legislation and
government which is something I don't
necessarily support right so I try to
always advocate for every one of my
political positions through a secular
worldview because that is the vast
majority of people and that's the actual
the government system that we have all
need to decided to create we do have a
separation of church and state and we
should support that with that being said
I can still have my own personal
opinions and my own personal you know
ways to go about changing public policy
but when we start to say we should
support this law because it's the
Christian thing to do that is I think
beginning that has turned people off for
the last 30 years what does it say also
about Christians that you know we talked
about gay marriage before that there was
a shift sure there actually has been a
shift now you're basically arguing it's
a political shift or utilitarian yes
you're just you're sort of giving me
just a realist argument yeah but is
there something else going on there to
where there is so could be mean
intolerance to tolerance in the truest
sense yeah and here's the other problem
with Christians and me being a
card-carrying member of this community
and I try my hardest and I fail is and
I'm around a lot of these Christians and
I sometimes fall into it is this
legalism right is that I'm somehow
better than you because I'm a Christian
and I really think that's done such a
disservice to the Christian community
especially the Christian conservative
community it's this sanctimonious
approach to lifestyle that I find to be
really off-putting to a lot of
non-believers and people say well I
don't want to be a Christian because
they're always going to talk down to me
or they're gonna make me live by this
set of beliefs oh they think they're
better than I am it's a number-one
critique I get it's not that oh I don't
believe Jesus Christ is actually the Son
of God or I don't believe the Bible you
know those are actually things I think
that could be ironed out it's more so
like I've always been talked down to her
when I was a young kid I was
Catholic school and they gave me these
15 things I couldn't do and because of
that I rebelled and rejected so I think
this idea that actually Jesus Christ
advocated for which is hey I dined with
the tax collectors I was best friends
with the prostitutes right like I never
thought that they were any better than
the my disciples right and I and of
course I don't live this out the best I
should but where Christians have gotten
it wrong is this fierce fire and
brimstone legal as thou shall all
homosexual you know like that's wrong
man
yea that's not that's not what the the
teachings and the evidence we have of
Jesus Christ life ever taught us he was
welcoming he was tolerant he was
accepting he had standards he was fierce
when it came to eternity in the
standards of God but he wasn't afraid to
go chill with tax collectors which were
considered like the lowest form of
individual possible in the Middle East
during that time right and so I think we
as Christians can learn a lot of that in
modern societies and when we wrap this
thing up you want to go have lunch with
some prostitutes I mean if they want to
hear about the good news of Jesus Christ
but even so right he's sometimes some
people are like oh you know but the
point being is we should we as
Christians have to do a better job of
not being the sanctimonious moral
conjectures which we get labeled at
summit and so much so when you see a guy
like Shapiro or a guy like Prager
preggers more than my here I love them
Prager basically a secular view at this
point but grew up Orthodox Shapiro
obviously is a observant religious there
have been Orthodox Jew you guys
basically from what I can tell agree on
pretty much everything politically
you're obviously more Trump than than
Shapiro is pretty fine on any given day
Prager definitely is more Pro Trump but
this does any of your religious
differences does I know that doesn't
matter to you in terms of poverty that's
very obvious but in just in terms of
like your humanity or the way your
worldview does any of that matter here
you know I've had wonderful discussions
Dennis Prager about what he believes
theologically and I mean look first of
all I think Dennis Prager is like the
Yoda of the conservative movement he's
like unbelievably brilliant told you
isn't that I know exactly he's he's
fantastic and same with Ben I mean I
listen to their stuff every single day
and Prager University does a heroic job
but it doesn't bother me at all but I
always challenge right
so I I challenge you know religious and
observing Jews with some pretty good you
know questions I think cuz I'm very big
in the apologetics of the New Testament
and the Christian you know the evidence
for you know Christianity I ask
questions I'll say do you believe Paul
existed in you know and do you think
Paul Osiris existed and they'll say yes
I'll say doesn't don't you think it's
kind of like weird that a Roman Jew
dropped this whole amazing lifestyle and
like went all-in for this Jesus Christ
thing and then got persecuted put in
jail six times and then reverse
crucified like would someone do that if
they actually didn't believe this that's
a provocative question obviously right
but I love that and I love that kind of
you know discussion and look Paul said
very clearly in the New Testament bless
the Jews you know these are your
brothers there is no New Testament out
the Old Testament so we agree you know
with the Jewish people and all that and
look I think we need more Jews to
actually become more observant and to
understand the roots of the Torah and
the roots of what God commanded their
Moses and through David and the the
major and minor prophets and I have such
great respect for them because they've
done a great job of I think awakening
people that there are you know Jewish
conservatives out there and it's okay to
believe these things well it's
interesting because as someone that
doesn't come from this from a religious
perspective I agree with the wider
principle that you're pushing here which
is that some of these minority
communities so in this case you're
talking about Jews but you reference
black people earlier which I want to
talk a little about what is working with
kandace but now I see it within the
Asian community I don't know if you just
saw in the last couple of days there's
this email that got leaked from Google
where they're basically were saying
we're gonna hire people but not white
men or Asian women will be treated like
white women or something something to
the horribly racist everything it's it's
the real reason they don't real racism
them yeah it's this kind of like it's
just there's this ranking of oppression
Olympics like somehow your skin color
makes you somewhat more you know worthy
of a position in a company or in a
university because you've been through
more just because you look different or
the scary part especially for the Asian
community is that your skin color and
the way you look is makes you less
worthy because you're gonna work real
hard and you're gonna have the right
decisions on the right decision I mean
make no mistake it's like an anti
American worldview that the left is now
essentially embraced it's like all
they've been successful enough now we
must discriminate against them so we can
help the it's like it's it's it's it's
lunacy but going back to your point of
the Christian conservative kind of
worldview I think there's a lot there's
a lot of us that hold these beliefs very
personal but also that's that's kind of
where we draw the line is you know we
have these personal beliefs and they're
gonna dictate how we want to live
individually but how do we advocate for
a society that allows the most amount of
people to advocate for their own
personal beliefs whatever they might be
as long as it doesn't harm someone else
so your basic argument I think you hit
on this a little bit earlier would be
that part of the reason that Europe is
crumbling which it is crumbling with the
West is crumbling except for America
yeah I mean we're so we're taping this
it's gonna go up next week but we're
taping this today is the three year
anniversary of well Charlie Hebdo was a
couple of years ago three years but
today was the day that they finally
caught the guy and then there was the
shooting at the kosher supermarket in
Somers and all that today a different
supermarket was burned down I mean this
is this is still happening in Paris
right now
and this is happening all across Europe
we know what's going on in Sweden all's
your basic premise would be that if they
had held on to some of their
judeo-christian values instead of
trading them in yeah well what do you
think secularism essentially statism
right but yet you're also a secularist
which is an interest no but no I don't
think it's not I don't think it's
contradictory because I would make an
argument that actually the separation of
church and state found in America has
helped the church we still have the
highest church-going grades rates in the
West we still the highest levels of
private flame we have more churches
opening than ever before the evangelical
community is growing in most states as
Alan Dershowitz would say the separation
of church and state has been the best
thing for the church because it's not
imposed upon people it's not mandatory
as you and I both agree when as soon as
you start to tell someone to do
something it becomes a lot less sexy and
appealing yeah it actually want to rebel
against that you want to reject it I
would argue Europe through their social
welfare programs have deteriorated the
church the as soon as they start to say
government is going to take care of
people government is going to be the
most important thing in your life
government's gonna fix these vastly
complex social problems then all of a
sudden the church and the individual
becomes far less significant as Dennis
Prager
the larger the government the smaller
the citizen you're seeing that play out
in France and Spain and Portugal and
Italy where you have individual
philanthropy disappear where you have
business startups Nessa totally
evaporate and the final point is what it
really lends itself to is more dangerous
ideologies to take forms such as radical
Islam which is I think one of the most
dangerous widespread ideological
movements happening the West that no one
is talking about and here's I can
understand I mean you're a gay guy I
mean I would probably be worried if I
start to see you know radical Islam
start to take root in Europe right
you're a Christian I'd be worried too no
I mean trust me I'm on that program okay
they want us both dead my friend right I
mean and that's something I find to be
horribly inconsistent with the left is
they try to be the champions of all
these minority groups and all these
supposed to depress groups yet here they
are kind of joining forces with
countries and movements and you know
theocratic fascists in the Middle East
that give homosexuals flying lessons on
the top of buildings all right so then
how do we I spend I think a good chunk
especially the first year of this show
trying to talk about radical Islam
making a distinction between radical
Islam and the nominal Muslim person who
practices our faith privately however
they do just like most sure people I try
to separate Islam as a set of ideas
worthy of criticism as Christianity is
and Jewish artists and republicanism and
all of that okay versus people versus
criticizing people and treating people
differently I think a lot of people in
our space have tried to do that and you
don't get a lot of credit for it but
okay fine I don't I don't need bonus
credit but how how do we talk about
radical Islam
well in an honest way and I do there is
a differentiation that needs to be drawn
but it also and we also do need to talk
about the broader implementation of an
is of an Islamic government in worldview
right so Islam as its core at its core
has always been and will always be tied
into the state and as soon as they can
demonstrate that they can be a majority
in a country and not be a theocratic
government then I'll start to cede some
territory against that so for example
Saudi Arabia right so if you are
Christian in Saudi Arabia you lose your
head if you're a Jew they'll find your
family and kill all of you that's
there's something wrong
that right so I think we need to draw a
great critique of that same in a land
which is Shia and Saudi which is Sunni
and there's something really I think not
correct about in modern society that you
have obviously a Muslim majority country
and you know there's no Christians and
no Jews and no churches and no
synagogues there's something very
intolerant about that however people
that want to reform Islam I'm your
biggest advocates right people that want
to go through a reformation of you know
Islam and try to differentiate that know
Islam does not have to be tied to the
state and yes Islam can be tolerant of
Christians and Jews and gays and the
modern feminist movement and they should
be allowed to vote and drive and you
know be able to make decisions as they
see fit and not have to wear a full
hijab I want those Muslims that succeed
I'm frightened that the more radical
voices which are in the tens of millions
if not hundreds of millions are actually
getting more more of an audience they're
they're they're creating you know
sectors of Europe that are quite
troubling that are advocating for the
advancement of these more dangerous
ideologies that support honor killings
and don't think women should have the
right to drive or to vote or to be able
to have representation any sort of form
of government and so I think a broader
critique of Islam needs to be put forth
because they've been doing it against
Christianity for the last 100 years I
walk into a lecture hall and I hear
about how important tolerant Christians
are and how they're terrible people find
hard stop you go to the Vatican a woman
is allowed to wear shorts and you know a
cut-off t-shirt you go to Mecca and
you're a Christian you get your head cut
off I mean you literally can't go no you
literally are not allowed they're
literally not a lot so there there's
there's a discussion that needs to
happen where a broader Reformation is
necessary but the more radical voices of
Islam are actually succeeding right now
you look at the most viral members of
the YouTube community in the Sunni you
know Saudi region but they're the ones
that are advocating for a holy war and
the extermination of Christians they're
the ones that are really taking root we
have to support we have to reinforce and
we have to really encourage the more
reformist muslims to get a broader you
know platform but i'm just not seeing it
yeah i mean i've tried to do a little
bit of it you know you've done
I've helped some reformers and some
ex-muslims and things like that but the
problem is that they're constantly
undercut by their own peat supposedly
their own people yeah every times one of
them talks about this they say you're a
sellout or you're sure evil or you know
what but it does beg the question and
like that the center of their faith is
the most intolerant city in the world
someone's got to take a broad stand
against that and maybe we'll see in the
next hundred years but commet been saman
you know the new Crown Prince of Saudi
Arabia is trying to do some more you
know modern changes but you're also
seeing extraordinary radical voices in
Saudi Arabia continually rise up you're
seeing protests in Iran which is great
but then you're seeing a lot of the
Western world not stand with these
protests you see President Trump is done
a great job of it Obama who was totally
silent
so look Islam in general there's there's
wonderful Muslim friends that I have and
productive members of the American
community that embraced this idea that
you can hold your beliefs without having
to have them push through a state which
is is great but you're also seeing the
exact opposite with them you know the
Muslim Brotherhood taking further route
in Egypt and in Turkey you're seeing you
know Saudi Arabia want to continue its
influence throughout the Arabian
Peninsula it's gonna be a conflict of
ideas and it's the largest religion I
believe in the world correct me if I'm
wrong 1.2 billion people
Christianity's right up against but I
would argue that Islam has a lot more
power in countries and Christianity does
it's a Reformation that needs to happen
so is the demographic time bomb in
Europe is it already too late it's
trouble in a way it's very troubling so
as a byproduct of supporting social
welfare programs in the 60s and 70s that
deteriorated the influence of the
Catholic Church and in Protestantism
throughout Europe and really just kind
of making people so apathetic towards
private philanthropy apathetic towards
value creation entrepreneurship rates
disappeared and you really created a
lazy European society I hate to say it
but they are not highly productive
people they take the month of August off
they have very little ambition there
okay being average that's not the
society I want to live in America has
always been aspirational we've been the
most productive we've been the risk
takers we've been we've been the
entrepreneurs so because of that they've
laid themselves to be remarkably
vulnerable to a takeover culturally and
demographically and you're starting to
see that with the millions of
relocations from the Middle East of
people that don't hold these views that
the Europeans hold in honestly they come
from a
grandmother bee Syria or Jordan or Yemen
or Oman Yemen there's a huge
humanitarian crisis happening they've
known nothing but government being
Islamic and so they inherently support
that but if they want to go through the
Reformation and they can demonstrate
they can do that great I'm not seeing
that though I'm seeing vast demographic
clashes happening all throughout Europe
there's also an interesting generational
piece to this which is that you find
that a lot of the older people that came
from those countries you know 30 years
ago they actually are more westernized
and they're torturing are now they're
sort of making up that there was
something imaginarily great about saddam
or their parents we need that we need to
reform the cat-lair you rebuild the
caliphate and very dangerous right and
so you look at the Reformation that
Christianity right rightfully went
through in the 1500s and 1600s and 1700s
it's as soon as you embrace the idea of
personal freedom and individual liberty
and you try to restrict the state so put
your put yourself in the in the in the
seat of the founding fathers they
intentionally removed any sort of
mention of Christendom in the
Constitution which end up being the best
thing for Christianity which created the
most Christian nation in the world which
is America think about how ironic that
is right whereas Europe then always do
that they actually created these
theocratic governments that led way to
you know horrible conflict and you know
ethno-nationalism and eventually in the
sixties and seventies like I mentioned
the huge proliferation of the welfare
state which was the worst decision
Europe ever made they turned a highly
productive people into a mediocre lazy
society that rejected all sorts of
religion and any sort of you know
connection to higher being and has now
led themselves to a demographic takeover
that I think is for worse some people
think it's for the better I just don't
see any evidence of that but again
there's nothing--there's and I I get I
get criticized as being a racist and all
this I'm not talking about a set of
ideas that when implemented through the
state have proven to be extremely
dangerous to human rights and economic
productivity and private property rights
and really human you know human dignity
so when you mentioned the phrase
oppression Olympics a couple of times
which obviously I totally buy in on
which is from your video I stole it from
you about
well I think I stole it from Faisal
Saitama ptarth and he probably stole it
from somebody so that's how these ideas
get around but this idea of this this
intersectional nonsense which is all
nonsense the how do you do you think
that the average last person in America
that you know says they're a feminist
and therefore what do you think that
they don't recognize any of the stuff
that you just said about obviously don't
talk about it but they might they might
they might recognize it they might know
about it they might be able to answer it
in a triple er Pursuit game but the
question is here so you're there's the
international feminist society which is
growing huge on campus I always
challenge them they advocate for women's
rights across the world and they're like
right next to like the Muslim Student
Association which is fine they should be
friends that's okay look but why are
they not demonstrating why it said
widespread protests against how women
are treated in Saudi Arabia but the
international feminist society is
protesting for against Israel yeah it's
weird right it's like because
intersectionality it's like they have
this weird construct that we must
advocate against Israel because Israel
is a friend of America and America hates
women it's like this weird like I need
like this big map like where they kind
of try it doesn't make any sense but
where is the outrage they say there's
outrage when I challenge them oh yeah
we're really outraged about it yeah okay
sure but no where's the where's the
where's the Oprah Winfrey's right
where's the Hillary Clinton's who spoke
multiple times and Saudi Arabia took
millions of dollars from now right where
women can't drive we're women Kelly now
they can drive and that's gonna be a
real disaster you know no it is because
all of a sudden they're just wait for
the Imams to get your hands and hands up
there women are in what do you mean oh
because they're gonna have a total
religious clash about this because um
had been some on say it said by decree
that women can drive and there's going
to be all these religious
fundamentalists that are not gonna allow
it to happen it's gonna be a total
conflict they were bragging that women
are allowed to go to movies now like
that to show you how medieval Saudi
Arabia is right anyway Hillary Clinton
made this like her pinnacle you know
point of her campaign is like I'm gonna
really have good relations with Saudi
Arabia her foundation took tens of
millions of dollars here was a woman
that ran on the idea of like feminist
representation right and she can't
critique Saudi Arabia once right but she
critiques Israel for the settlements
right so I think there's unbelievable
apakah see there but it's not just Saudi
Arabia which I'm focusing on it's Egypt
it's a ran it's Iraq which is changing
its Syria it's Jordan it's online it's
Yemen the only countries that get it
right or Qatar right and maybe the UAE
but you have you have a geographic
disposition of hundreds of millions of
square miles where women cannot vote
women cannot own property women cannot
start businesses women cannot serve in
governments men have total and absolute
control over society gays they asked
academia job they said how do you how do
you treat have no yeah how do you treat
gays in your society we do not have all
the sex rows in our country that's great
where's the where's the LGBT
International Society protesting against
that right it's like they have this kind
of like handshake like we're not going
to mention this it's all good that can't
stand anymore right and then what what
country did I hate the most of course
its Israel where we're days are open you
know are openly productive members of
society I think they can marry in Israel
not sure but I the West has been the
best to women and to gays and yet they
want to destroy the West which doesn't
make any sense to me by the way you
mentioned settlements a minute ago I
think that Jesus guy you referenced
before he lived in a town called
Bethlehem and where what he was born in
that lands in the West yeah exactly
Jesus of Nazareth yeah minor details
here right yeah but history though is
just lost on people right is that like
to me that's one of the most it's whole
things like it's just that people don't
know basics about history well even it's
it's the basics but it's just like the
ignorance of understanding the the the
blessings we have the live in Western
civilization and how unique what we
really have here is a country and it's
being taught in our universities how
America's a racist xenophobic
imperialist horrible country and you
really have to try it takes effort to
try to make that argument because
America has been one of the greatest if
not one of the greatest ideas ever
implemented in human history and civil
society it's had more respect for human
rights it's had more economic
productivity we have freed more people
from serfdom and from bondage and any
other country we voluntarily sent our
citizens and our civilians and our
soldiers to die for the freedoms of
others without asking for anything in
return you look at the Korean War we
send you know our boys from Iowa Kansas
South Carolina and Fleur
go die in the Korean Peninsula 50,000 of
them so that South Korea can exist we
asked for nothing in return if we were
imperialist where the worst imperialist
ever right and so yet it takes the
effort to really look at look at history
and say that we're a horrible place and
this is what the modern American Left is
trying to do is like remember when I
send the beginning of the video we have
a choice we can either go the way of
Europe and totally fundamentally
transform this country and embrace a set
of ideas we've never had or we can
defend respect and advance American
ideas here and really try to make the
21st century the greatest we've ever had
is there an inherent risk in some of
that though that yes there are things
like South Korea that work out there's
always on foreign policy yeah I mean
there's a lot of instances yeah we've
had ones blunders I mean Iraq war was a
total mistake yeah it was a disaster so
they so there that's just the inherent
risk in this basically I know that was
sanctioned by the way by Congress in the
Senate and sure the United was intact of
War of authorization it was a conflict
but so what I meant there is a broader
point that throughout the 20th century
America has stepped up and fought for
the freedom and liberty of others not
ever asking for something returned I
would argue that Iraq was it was a
horrible response the 9/11 had nothing
to do with the actual existential
threats against the homeland that was
george w bush trying to rectify a
mistake that his father didn't actually
make which was takeover you know saddam
hussein's empire we got next to nothing
we lost 30,000 american troops we spent
two trillion dollars we didn't have and
we helped create Isis to boot so
imposing American ideas worldwide is not
something that I would have ever
advocate for but argue but when when the
chips are down for example you know in
World War two and you know the Nazi
Empire is on the March and they're
sixteen miles away from Moscow and you
know Winston Churchill is on his hands
and knees begging FDR to send troops
then we send you know half a million
ground troops to go through Normandy we
stepped up right and we helped push back
European fascism so look there's been a
lot of mistakes some of our incursion in
Central America were total disasters but
net-positive Americas you know decisions
throughout the 20th century have helped
you know advance human freedom and and
release people from bondage so to that
end you must love what Trump's doing
with the UN right oh it's that are you
Haley is a freaking all-star I mean I
here's all about Nikki Haley and to my
left is people watching this yeah how
can you not recognize she's everything
you pretend to advocate for notice your
cousin she's she's a son daughter of an
immigrant
she's a minority you know and she's
Indian I mean like from actual India
right which is one of their I think
oppression Olympics Kurtz what you saw
this thing like a couple weeks ago where
they were trying to mock her for using
the name Nikki and it's like that's what
her parents called I know imagine if a
Republican said that there's a mark
she's totally self-made her father
literally owned convenience stores
started at a state senator ran as an
insurgent for governor twice elected
eradicated the Confederate flag from her
State Capitol balance the budget created
South Carolina into this unbelievably
prosperous state in a very complicated
political state by the way by the way
they always said you know the south is
so racist well they yell twice elected
you know a woman minority governor of a
state that you call you know the new you
know Confederacy anyway what about a
night Tim Scott guy exactly one of the
only there's only two african-american
senators and one of them's from what
they call one of the most racist states
in the country that's aside the point
yeah then should get selected by
President Trump who supposedly hates
women but he hasn't represent us in the
UN to go fiercely fight against all
these globalist forces at the UN cuts
aid to the Pakistan she is what the left
is supposed to love right she is the she
is this absolute embodiment of
modern-day feminism yeah they hate her
did you see this tweet the other day by
the at Democrats you know the official
oh yeah well all the check marks yeah
women club up qualifying woman but the
bet well that of course that's that's
like the blankey response but the best
was leaked so it was like you know do
you minority women brown women but a the
amount of people who dress wrote it all
right you're endorsing nikki Haley and
it's like man you guys this is what you
idiots have created that's right there
and I can't tell you it's really
interesting because so many of our
turning point members and our turning
point students I say why are you
conservative I'm a student I'm not
concerned because of the left I left the
left because of the left because they
have lost their freaking mind like if
they were just like normal Democrats and
didn't say the stupid stuff and of
intersectionality politics and like they
argue that well we can run government
better but free enterprise is a good
thing but flawed we need a per we need
to get perfect
and you know if they actually had some
humility for it instead of just like
embracing cultural Marxism and doing the
oppression Olympics I think you might
still be on the left instead they've
created the greatest gift thank you
liberals for doing this leftist because
now we have like former Bernie Sanders
supporters running our chapters because
they are now cultural Marxists that
looked at people how to call their skin
by how much value they have in the world
or how great you can understand
someone's you know that you know degree
of suffering which is everything that
Martin Luther King argued against which
is everything that has fundamentally
created this country and so thank you
leftist for helping create this movement
for us are there any good Democrats left
oh sure there I had my issues with
plenty of Republicans and I'd be more
you should have a Rand Paul Republican
man delivered to him aboard yeah do you
want to join the I call dumbass if evil
empire you could join the resist the
real resist there was the real
resistance I mean look the stuff that I
like about Randolph and Paul obviously
is all the libertarians of course
sadly in that collection of 18 people
that were running against Trump he was
seemingly on the wrong stage it just the
party had nothing to do with yeah that
time what he wanted even if as you've
said before Trump may be doing a lot of
days those things right now would show
you how sharePlex this whole very
compliant but look the question I think
you had was but the new generator like
any good Democrats is there any one now
that you sure I'm still looking for that
kind of like Blue Dog Democrat to rise
up and be like you know I'm a Democrat
that is pro-choice which I disagree with
whatever that is you know all these
things but I still think America is a
great country and we need to like rid
our our country of antiva Alan
Dershowitz is probably only one I could
think of right now
whose bill the way he's getting kicked
out of the Democrat Party everybody
abuse he's taking I'm saying this every
week what is it since when has it been a
bad thing to be Alan Dershowitz I mean
the guy is freaking brilliant like you
might disagree with him but he's like
the smartest lean a lawyer and human
rights attorney that you could possibly
find and now the Democrats been like
he's Ark she's being paid by the Trump
campaign like are you kidding me yeah I
mean he's brilliant and they're kicking
him up yeah that's love that meant so
yeah there are some good Democrats out
there Charlie I suspect we could do this
for a couple more hours but if you want
to I'm only gonna ask you one mocha
because I want this on the record on
this show but when it happens it should
be that I asked at first you're gonna
run for so now
not for political office I want to I
want to be a be a commentator in a
movement driver does that have anything
to do with the clown show that that
running is that a guy like you who you
obviously have a great understanding of
the issues you have a consistent line of
thought whether I agree with you and
every bar to principle no but there's
something to be said for I think so I
mean that goes to what Quercus said
about he's broker right I think but but
in all reality I love what I got to do
seriously like every day I get to create
a movement and help facilitate a movie
not create well in say what I want to
say and be able to you know have
conversations to you on all this stuff
I've met very few Congress people are
senators or governors that actually
enjoy what they do seriously and it's
always about meeting with lobbyists or
Cao telling the leadership and
fundraising it just makes me sick to my
stomach thinking about that but let's
pretend it was a great gig which some of
them seem to like it I don't know why
they like the corruption or something
like is that really a place where I can
do the most amount of good for my
worldview and I would say probably not
no I'd say look turning points doing a
great service for the country I think
right now I love what I get to do I've
you know have some influence and helping
shape this policy in this agenda and
that doesn't seem like fun to me it
doesn't seem like that would maximize my
amount of happiness yeah alright why
it's on the record now it's on the
record I talk like a politician I think
we're doing a gig together in New
Hampshire yeah I'll be fine not too long
from now so when we get in Tannis will
be there too and Canada's Owens will be
quick yeah sure let's just finish
talking again about Candice for a moment
so when I when I met you that day I
referenced that literally a minute
before you had I saw it from a distance
you and Candice talked for about two
minutes
and then she walked over to me and she's
like I just got a job with turning-point
Charlie wants me to you know help talk
to the black community in blah blah blah
she's quickly becoming an all-star in
this space I think she escaped some of
the YouTube madness which I'm somewhat
aware of and you may have seen my insane
debate with her and Blair white and blah
blah blah but she's quickly becoming a
real powerhouse Hodel or else because
the black community has needed more Pete
you know the Thomas souls and Larry
elders
and david webs and who have alan west
whoever out there it's a different
generation she's coming at it from the
from that's correct
young place it's kind of beautiful she's
unbelievably talented i've spent a
considerable amount of time with her now
- the five minutes i hired her but she's
a passionate driven person looked
broader than that she like like all of
us on our team believe and understand
there is a movement happening in this
country and it's something the media
will not report it's something palpable
when you experience it you saw it in
florida there's something happening in
this everything crazy and it's it's
almost quasi spiritual political it's
there's something happening because the
left has tried for far too long to
suppress the movement of ideas and free
speech and dialogue and discussion but
what Candice believes which I'm in full
support of and I want to help her in
every way possible is that the
african-american community has been
totally dis served for lack of a better
term by the modern Democratic Party and
that they are disproportionately more
poor they're disproportionately in worse
circumstances than people of every other
you know ethnic racial group but why is
that it's not because America is a more
racist country than we were in the 1960s
in fact no one with a straight face
could possibly say that yet African
Americans are poor today than they were
in the 1960s so what happened to use a
Hillary Clinton term America did not get
more racist America got significantly
less racist there still racism in this
country but a lot of it has been
eradicated if not reversed it what
happened is that we as Americans
supported one of the most you know I
would say contentious political and
social programs which was the great
society where we D incentivize the black
community from making good choices we
incentivized women to say single and
have babies
we destroyed public sector education by
reinforcing the public sector teacher
unions and disallowing school choice and
rewarding bad teachers and keeping
communities perpetually poor we I think
really did a disservice by have you
starting this war on police in the last
couple years which most police officers
are there for the betterment of the
communities that they police and we have
started this narrative that America is
somehow an inherently racist country and
African Americans are poor because we're
a racist country the data does not
reflect that it's because we have
created a set of government policies
ideas that have not incentivized
african-americans to continually make
good choices that break out of poverty
and as Ben Shapiro says you make these
three choices you get married before you
have kids you graduate high school and
you get a job you can break out of
poverty in this country and we you could
look to all three of those things we
have government programs that either
discourage or D incentivize every one of
those choices especially for African
American community and at Candis going
up from the poor family going up as a
you know african-american woman in this
culture and society can talk about a lot
better than I can I can only talk about
it from an outsider
she's an insider which in today's time
unfortunately buys you a lot more
institutional credibility which it
really shouldn't right I mean that's the
irony it's it's it's sort of using
identity politics itself what you almost
have to what you almost have to do
because if for Xavier greatest way to
solve poverty and canvas says it it
doesn't make it any more lesser true
just because she's a black woman right
truth is truth no matter who says it but
the left somehow has a value you know a
lot higher if certain people saying it
but you know what if identity politics
is what we have to play then so be it
and Candis understands that especially
on college campuses black students but
listen to her a lot more likely than
they'll listen to me and I believe that
she can continually build a movement
around these core set of ideas and
values and principles and she gets it
because she used to be one of them she
used to be a leftist she understands who
these people are and she understands how
to fight them and how to persuade and
she we're lucky to have her as our
director of urban engagement at Turning
Point USA I know you don't like drug
references but when I had her on I said
you know for me it was like the red pill
was like I was like slowly drinking it
like tea she said she snorted it all the
power to hurt as long as I didn't harm
someone else do whatever you want to do
with your life I wanted to end with you
in a slightly awkward position here we
go NAB your employees that there we go
that seems very good listen you're doing
great stuff I'm thank you forward to to
getting out on the road with you and
well you're doing a lot also you don't
know a mouth hurt at the end of that
week because you're smiling some oh I
literally at one point I could not smile
anymore I can't is it we're in art
students just great I mean they were
just and by the way speaking of standing
ovations I mean Candice got a massive
massive ovation everyone got it I mean
everybody hears I think that's the
diversity of ideas is we will give a
standing ovation of people even if we
don't agree with what they have to say
completely right and that's the left
won't do that it's like get out of my
room get out of mice get out of our you
know lecture hall and it's a movement
around true tolerance and true
discussion of ideas and we're gonna win
all right well to find out more about
Charlie's 2028 campaign for presidency
follow him on the twitter at charlie
kirk 11:00
[Music]